MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Hi.
My name is Mamie
Rheingold, and I
will be your host for this
issue of Google Developers Live.
And today we're
focusing on DIY.org.
DIY.org is a site,
and a community
where kids can learn new skills
and share what they've learned.
And each member gets a portfolio
where they can show off
all the skills that
they've learned.
Everything from
beekeeping and dancing,
to astronomy and filmmaking,
and rapid prototyping.
And today, I am joined
by four different DIYers
from around the
world, all tuning in
through Google Hangout.
And they've all earned
programming-related badges.
So we want to learn more about
how they learned to program,
and how people like
you guys can help.
So first, I want to turn
it over to Diana, from DIY,
to tell us a little
bit more about DIY.
DIANA WATTANAPONGSAKOM:
Yeah, so DIY, as you said,
is an online
community where kids
can learn different skills.
And what's really
awesome about it
is that we see this sort of
community sort of dynamically
growing by themselves.
Kids are basically teaching
themselves these skills,
and collaborating
with other members,
in the variety
communities in ways
through creating
their own websites,
or starting DIY newspapers, and
collaborating with one another
to complete projects, and earn
skills that they've sometimes
never even heard of before.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD:
Cool, and so let's
turn it over to the
DIYers themselves.
I'd love for you guys to
each introduce yourself.
ZACH: I'll start then.
Hi my name is Zach.
I'm a DIYer, both on the
site and I also work for DIY.
So I think that's cool.
So I'm 16.
My favorite programming
skill, I mean I've done a lot.
And I'm just kind of
testing when working.
But definitely I like
the front-end developer
and back-end developer.
Those are kind of my favorites.
Of my non-programmer ones,
[? variety ?] and all that,
the photographer one is one
that's really fun to do.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Great.
Zoe?
ZOE: Hi.
I'm Zoe.
I'm eight years old.
And my favorite DIY skill that's
not related to programming
is meme hacker.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Meme hacker?
Do you know-- what kind of
programming do you know?
ZOE: I program mostly in Python.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Cool.
Awesome.
ZOE: Also in HTML.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Oh man,
front-end and back-end.
Cool.
Eli, will you
introduce yourself?
ELI: Hello, my name is Eli
Cujo, and I'm on DIY and stuff.
And I really like the
open sourcer DIY school,
because really like
the whole community
aspect of coding
and stuff like that.
And DIY as an open
source community
has helped me, as well
as other open source.
So open source is a very good
learning resource for me,
in helping me learn a lot
of stuff about coding.
And then my other skill that I
like that's not part of coding
is the ornithologist skill.
I really like that skill.
It's about birds and stuff.
And I really like birds and bird
watching and nature and stuff.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Nice.
And last but not least, Ginny,
will you introduce yourself?
GINNY: Hi, I'm Ginny.
I'm 11 years old.
And I've earned Newb, I
think that's about it.
But my favorite skill that
isn't programming is animator.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Whoa, cool.
That's awesome!
You guys have done
so many things.
I love it!
So just to learn a little
bit more about DIY,
and why you guys
love it so much, Eli,
will you share with us your
favorite thing about DIY?
ELI: Yeah, my favorite
thing about DIY
is that it's, as I said before,
it's like an open community
that you could learn so many
things from other people.
You could teach
other people things,
like there's no-- it's a
learning experience as well
as a fun one.
A lot of times experiences
can be educational and fun,
but one is higher
than the other.
But I like how DIY
is exactly 50%.
It's really nice
how you learn a lot,
and you also have tons
of fun at the same time.
It's very-- I like it a lot.
That's my favorite thing, the
education and the fun balance.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Yeah, and it
seem super collaborative, too.
I noticed you can comment on
projects, and fork projects.
ELI: Yeah, it's really there's
lots of-- you don't just
post something and
then it's just there.
You can comment
on it and fork it,
which means that people, if
they have the same idea as you,
they could share it with you.
They can show their
idea as well as yours.
And then there's
favoriting, and then there's
you can get featured,
as well, which
is you're featured
on the home page.
And it's like a community,
it's a very nice community.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Cool.
And since we want to learn
more about how you guys started
to learn programming,
Ginny, tell us more.
So you've earned the Newb badge.
So why did you start?
Why did you decide
to earn that skill?
GINNY: Well, three
days after Christmas,
I dropped all my Christmas
presents, and went and followed
this link from the Newb skill,
which was to MIT's programming
website, Scratch.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Oh, cool!
GINNY: It's a programming
site for kids.
It really got me started.
And then I got into
Khan Academy after that.
And from there I
learned JavaScript.
And I'm getting a
little bit into HTML.
I'm really interested in that.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: This
is all since Christmas?
GINNY: Yes.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Whoa.
GINNY: Not since this Christmas.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: OK,
I was going to say,
that would be crazy speed.
That's awesome!
So you've been coding
for a year now?
GINNY: Yes.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Really cool.
And then, and so
Zoe, you're eight,
and I've heard that you've
known that you have wanted
to be a programmer
since you were five.
So I'd love to learn
more about what
inspired you to want
to become a programmer
and what do you want to do with
these skills when you grow up.
ZOE: Well, my parents
introduced me to Khan Academy,
and my favorite part
of that was the coding.
So then she introduced me to
another website for coding.
And then I started learning
Python from a book.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Whoa, cool.
Have you made anything with
Python or any of the code
that you've learned?
ZOE: Not much yet, though.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: OK.
Well, you've got an early start.
I feel good about your
future as a programmer.
You've got a lot of
years ahead of you.
And Zach, so you're
here and you've actually
grown up to be a
programmer as a teenager.
So I want to hear
more about that.
What's it like to actually
be a programmer for DIY?
And you're still in
high school, right?
ZACH: Yeah, I'm in high school.
I mean it's good.
Yeah, I've always been
kind of a fan of teenagers
getting out and doing more
than the average part-time job,
which I guess is what
has led me to DIY.
And so I started about a
year and a half ago, I guess.
I mean, when I started I
definitely was not that good.
I mean I thought
I was, but, hey.
And it's just been
a really great ride.
I mean all the people
I work with are great.
And they're great at mentoring,
and just overall good people.
And I've learned so much and
I've done-- I've got to speak
and I've got to do so many
things because of programming,
which I think that's cool.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Yeah, I'm
excited to see your project
later on.
Cool.
And so when you're
just starting,
so I want to learn more
about how you guys actually
learned how to program.
So Ginny, will you start to
tell us about how you learned?
You mentioned Scratch and
Khan Academy, earlier.
GINNY: Well, I just
went into Scratch,
followed some of
their tutorials.
And soon I was figuring a
lot of things out on my own.
My first project was just
this picture of a ninja,
and if you pressed different
buttons on the keyboard,
then he would change poses.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Nice.
Fighting ninja.
GINNY: From there I
progressed so much,
in the first couple of weeks.
And I just took off, and I
was making a lot of things
from generators to platformers.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Cool.
And Eli, will you share
with us more about how
you started to learn
how to program?
ELI: When I was younger,
when I was eight, I started,
I got into-- I read
a lot, and I really
want to start a website
about book reviews.
It was sort of like
a dream or whatever,
and I researched a little
bit and I figured out
that I could actually
do this, somehow.
And I used a couple
of small software.
And I used HTML
mostly, and I sort of
started creating my website.
At first it started out
with just a blank background
and then a couple
of bodies of text.
But then eventually, as
I learned more and more
through the internet,
my website progressed.
And of course, it's not
published or anything
because it was just
sort of a page thing.
It wasn't on the internet.
But that's how I
got into coding,
was I wanted to
have this website.
And I researched
and I just found out
that, oh, it's
actually possible.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Cool.
And then how have you
progressed through your learning
through DIY?
ELI: Oh, well with DIY,
like as I said before,
I just knew just
HTML, just the basics.
But then when I went
on DIY, the skills
like a back-end dev
and front-end dev,
introduced me to other types of
code, and how those codes work.
Like Raptor, how it's
back-end dev and stuff.
And CSS, and that really
helps with spicing up
my HTML and stuff.
I learned different codes
that could help me out
through my website
making, and other stuff.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Cool.
Yeah, cool.
And so most of our
listeners are grownups,
and so I want them
to walk away knowing
how they can go help
kids like you to program.
So Zoe, have there
been any adults
that have helped you along
the way and anything that
made it super helpful,
or not helpful
for you learn how to program?
ZOE: Yes, my dad has
helped me with Python,
and taught me how to make it so
you can, it asks you a question
and you can type an answer,
and it will give you a result.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Cool.
Yeah, it's so magical
when it actually responds.
Is there anything
that your dad has
done that's made it easier
to learn how to code?
ZOE: Well, he gave me
the book about Python.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Super helpful.
What book is that?
ZOE: It's "Python for Kids."
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: Cool.
Sounds like an
appropriate book for you.
Cool.
Awesome.
I would love to
actually see a demo.
So Zach, will you
share the coolest thing
that you've created with code?
ZACH: Yeah, totally.
So let me just pull it up.
So, this kind of started
off as a joke project.
It's called dogescript.
So if you've ever seen the
doge meme on the internet,
which is quickly becoming very
overused, but it's still funny.
I kind of started
this as a joke.
Basically I was
like, what if there
is a programming language that
was based on the doge meme,
and would compile to JavaScript,
how-- all this copy script,
and type script.
And so, I kind of did
it one night as a joke.
And then this is what happened.
A lot of people
started contributing.
Well, someone else had
posted it on Hacker News.
And it just kind of blew up.
So a lot of people found it,
and it became this-- well,
so many people were
really into it.
It's just cool.
It's on GitHub, so like
open source MIT license.
And people they've contributed
so many things, poll requests
and I mean there's 15
contributors for what's
completely a joke language.
But it's a good joke
language, but at the same time
you could actually
program things,
and people have, which
is really funny to see.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD: The
beauty of the internet.
Love it.
And the Wowser.
That's great.
Cool.
Well, this has been
super fun for me.
Before we sign off, is
there any last advice anyone
wants to share to
the Google Developers
out there that are tuning in?
ZACH: I would say,
when you're trying
to get kids and
teenagers interested,
don't over-force it on them.
So many people tried
to really force it.
If a kid or teenager doesn't
like it, they don't like it.
And move on to something else
they're passionate about.
That's kind of basic
advice I can give.
I mean, that's for anything,
but really for programming, it's
definitely true.
MAMIE RHEINGOLD:
Yeah, love that.
And go help kids learn what
they're passionate about.
Thank you, guys.
This has been super fun.
And Google Developers
out there, I
hope you've been inspired by
these young kids who already
know how to code, and
you're excited about going
out and helping more
kids in your community
learn how to code.
There are some great
resources that they mentioned.
And also remember to
check out DIY.org.